I love so much that even after all the
lessons learned that you are not the
type of person that goes like oh like so
you do this big HBO special right yeah
that's like very well very well received
among some people among some people yeah
yeah was it not who didn't really not
like it though no I'm never mind never
mind was it's all good it's a shame well
it is Shane uh yes man Gillis oh I
mentioned Kris in one of the podcasts I
mentioned you enjoyed and you were I
think felt you were pissed about that
yeah he he spent about 10 minutes
explain oh why he didn't like that
special and why he felt like it made me
as he put it a white [ __ ] move on with
you did you guys ever talk about that he
called me it turned out so that you pick
up your phone for another because it's I
don't do that I'm a receptionist it it
turned out that we are at the same
management company I believe someone
gave him my number and said can you
please there's I had obviously been
communicating with my managers about I
don't feel this is okay and to put it
lightly so I got a text at about 8:00 in
the morning from him though so I came in
at Shane when can we talk we got on the
phone and I said a bunch of stuff I'd
say and he apologized so I was happy to
let it go but I wasn't thrilled
I wasn't octobot because one of those
things were sometimes you forget that
when we're bashing people we all do it
like we family oh there's a real person
there and then you guys talk in his
prime feel he probably felt badly [ __ ]
is Krista good dude anybody feels I
would hope that he feels worse now
because such a problem that he went
through was that sort of comics trashing
Comics thing yeah and you know what I
mean and sometimes you don't even
realize that you're doing it yeah if he
hadn't called you a white [ __ ] would
you still be mad that he criticized the
special I was more mad about the stuff
with the special like when I listened to
what he said when I saw the headline
come I had friends start texting me like
dude what's going on
I was like I don't know what your time
with that Google your name I see it's
like all these headlines coming up I was
like oh this ain't good man and that was
one of the things I said when when he
got me on the phone he's like how you
doing man I was like well here's how I'm
doing like I got a 5 at the time I was I
have a 5 month old son
asleep in the next room and much bigger
things to worry about that a person I've
never met attacking me and at making
national headlines like that's how I'm
doing like and I could kind of went off
and kept saying like cuz I went and
listened to the audio and it's it
started with a real funny line that made
me laugh he's like I got a turn on HBO
and see this guy standing on a carpet
making a bunch of girls cry who are
sitting in beanbag chairs and I was like
that's funny let me take that all of a
sudden it was like this baguette he
starts making specifically fun of the
story about how I tried to crash that
car which is like tried to [ __ ] kill
myself and he said at one point I mean
it went on for minutes and minutes and
he goes if you like comedy how could you
ever support Chris Gethard and that's
the point where I'm like just told him
on the phone I was like dude my act
might be soft but ask comics in town
like I have earned my respect like I've
been doing it for a lot of [ __ ] years
I think most people view me as a guy who
just worked really hard I do a lot of
you know and do a lot of stuff that's a
little weird by most people's standards
but for 20 years I've been in this town
making it work for myself paying my rent
I actually give him a lot of credit for
apologizing I was actually more upset
because I felt like there were so many
comics who I know so publicly going we
gotta get gotta get this guy's back and
protect free speech and I believe we
need to protect free speech in comedy
but would have been nice to get a text
from some of those people getting my
back too and I only heard from when I
say three or four people I was like man
comedy is full of [ __ ] snakes well
you also hear Chris raised a good like I
didn't even look again I was I was kind
of on the periphery just I just know I
know the guys are and I know them but I
heard so you at the cellar one night and
you were talking about yeah camaraderie
with comics and all this cuz people were
saying hey the comics gotta stick and
you'll get but he attacked me how's it
going I guess he like you know beat
people didn't think of that when they
were and I I think a lot of people read
the headline that he called that he said
the homophobic stuff and just kind of
like that's weird but when you listen to
the actual I think not many people
listen to the actual audio and I mean
like and it's hard it's hard not to get
paranoid and feel like man no no I got
two calls the night it went down and one
was from Judd Apatow so that doesn't
even count cuz he called me and Judd
suppose you guys talk about sex
[Laughter]